when we talk about the crisis involving
the separation of migrant kids at the
border from their parents and the
subsequent caging and internment camps
of children a common a couple of common
arguments actually from the right from
the defenders of the policy are number
one when you commit a crime in the
United States even as an American
citizen you don't go to prison or jail
with your kids so the separation really
isn't a big deal second argument is they
are breaking the law
after all this of course ignores that
illegally crossing into the United
States the first time you do it is is
only a civil offense and it also ignores
that seeking asylum at the border isn't
a crime at all but okay the defenders of
the policy will sometimes make that
argument we've also heard another
argument from the defenders of this
policy who say that it doesn't matter
what the Constitution says because the
Constitution only applies to u.s.
citizens not to people who are trying to
come into the United States this ignores
that actually much of the Constitution
does apply to all persons although there
are some specific parts which apply only
to u.s. citizens but we're gonna put
that aside for now as well this is now
being turned up a notch the Trump
administration has admitted that they
have separated a family who appeared to
be United States citizens for up to what
seems to be a period of a year I believe
that everybody should be treated with
respect I am NOT pointing this out
because I think it is worse to do this
to u.s. citizens than to non citizens
and some kind of moral sense but it does
immediately deflate one of the arguments
that we have heard from the American
right and the defenders of the policy
the Department of Justice said to a
federal judge this week that it appears
to have separated a father and toddler
both of whom appear to be American
citizens as part of the enforcement of
this policy and as I've been telling you
the administration was supposed to have
all five years of age and under kids
reconnected with their families by
Tuesday that didn't happen they were
told that in that case they need to
account for the whereabouts of every
single one of these cases during the
hearing about that the Trump
administration said that one of the 27
cases where reunification wasn't
currently feasible is a case where the
parents low
patien has been unknown for more than a
year and records show that the parent
and child might be American citizens the
government lost track of the parent the
kid is in custody at one of these
facilities for migrant children and they
both appear to be American citizens we
should all be asking wait wait a second
this case with the citizens has been
going on for a year we only found out
about it because of the escalation of
the policy which led to a u
reunification deadline which led to the
DOJ having to explain what's going on
with each kid how long was this going to
be kept secret were it not for the judge
saying hey DOJ you've got to account for
every one of these kids and most
shockingly this isn't as rare as you
think ice is the immigrations and
customs enforcement of Department
Organization and based on a report by
Vice in 2016 not only does ice sometimes
detain US citizens they sometimes deport
US citizens there is a report which
suggests from Northwestern that in 2010
more than four thousand US citizens were
detained or deported as aliens maybe a
stupid question
but if someone's an American citizen
which country do you deport them to in
most cases its Mexico as it was in 2010
and all we need to remember is that
Trump wanted to suspend due process for
people believed to be in the country
illegally he casually treat tweeted
about it
we're deporting some US citizens if
anything we need to slow down the
process not speed it up yeah I'd have to
imagine that the US citizens who are
deported are of Hispanic or Latino
descent and you know what was the what's
the way to stop this from happening
right are they supposed to keep some
documentation in their pocket maybe
present their absolute last port upon
request show us your papers at any time
you need to have your full documentation
with you at any time and why do I think
that that wouldn't actually solve the
problem they'd still figure out some way
to explain why that's not that that's
just not going to be sufficient I hope
that this will be a dark stain on
American history and the phrase of the
day
is slow creep authoritarianism doesn't
happen all at once
it is a slow creep and we are seeing it
today's program sponsored in part by
blinkers comm slash Pakman I've talked
about blinkers before it's this awesome
app that I've been using for several
months now and what it does is take the
best and most critically acclaimed
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting you could
listen to ten books in an afternoon I
know that many in our audience want to
expand their horizons and learn more
about all sorts of different topics but
we're mostly limited by time to some
degree I know I'm not able to read all
of the books that I want simply because
I've got other stuff going on and that's
why blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to be li NK is t.com
slash PA k ma n